jean castex et jean michel blanquer air
sont arrivés à conflans sainte honorine
aux alentours de 10 heures au collège du
bois dole pour une rentrée lourde en
émotions c'est là qu'on saigne et samuel
pâtit professeur d'histoire-géographie
assassiné par un terroriste le 16
octobre dernier ils étaient présents
pour échanger et soutenir l les équipes
pédagogiques qui prépare le retour des
élèves attendus dès demain à des
psychologues de l'éducation nationale
seront présents dans toutes les classes
pour revenir sur cet événement tragique
a mené en hommage national a été rendu
dans toutes les écoles de france à 11
heures après cet échange avec les
professeurs du collège du bois donne
jean castex s'est rendu dans l'école
primaire située juste derrière moi dans
une classe de cm2 où il est resté une
trentaine à deux minutes après avoir
dialogué avec les équipes pédagogiques
jean castex s'est joint aux élèves pour
lire la lettre de jean jaurès la classe
ensuite observé une minute de silence je
vous le disais les enfants ont donc
repris le chemin de l'école dès ce lundi
matin avec une grande nouveauté le port
du masque obligatoire à des la primaire
vous vous habituerez a déclaré le
premier ministre aux élèves de l'école
duclos d'en haut concernant le port du
masque le chef du gouvernement s'est
également entretenu avec les autorités
locales sur la mise en place du nouveau
protocole sanitaire est également sur le
renforcement de la sécurité des
établissements scolaires passées au
niveau urgence attentats du plan
vigipirate